my husband spends over ,000 a month just
on phone games on his iPhone when you
say that out loud does it sound as crazy
to you as it does to me yes like this is
this is this is like illness level
what's your household income 83,000
$83,000 how old is your husband 29 okay
I'm a stay-at-home mom yeah am the one
that pays the bills yeah I pinch money
wherever I can okay so that we can get
those paid you're you you guys need to
see you need to get some professional
help that's what I'm thinking too yeah
because this is not a
$100 uh and he makes 200,000 they've
carefully designed the games to create a
dopamine hit to cause you to come back
again and again and again they designed
these games to be addictive